do you think  i um i'll be in denial if i said that  having two parents in a household  doesn't have a benefit especially for me  i have two boys and i'm a woman and i  act a hundred percent like a woman i can  never teach my son how to be a man um so  i take full accountability in that area  but however i still felt even though i  couldn't teach my sons how to be men  being around a certain type of man  wasn't good for them because even  being around certain type of men wasn't  good for them right because there's  certain attributes you pick up and i  don't want my sons to be like that  because i think the way i raise my kids  now i raise them as if the men i want  them to become so even already there  they're four and five and i give them  certain responsibilities and they're  very independent already so the delete  the best i can do i will do but i do  accept that i may not do enough for them  to become the men i want obviously i  don't